I actually think that in some weird and
it is a very emotional thing but some
weird twisted up fateful way this
character who you know has searched her
whole life for purpose actually finds
her purpose and it's like this amazing
super emotional beautiful thing I don't
judge people in their worst mistakes
[Music]
maybe you said you didn't
I feel very fortunate it's been an
incredible gift as an actor to be able
to come back to a character that's as
complex as Natasha I think there's a
kind of a lot to explore there and that
is so exciting
[Music]
Robert has a whole career of great work
behind him and he was at a point in his
life in his career what he was ready to
break out and do something really big
and exciting Shawn was in love with the
idea of Donnie playing the part and we
all felt so sure about him on a creative
level because he wasn't instantly a
slam-dunk approval I suggested we have
screen tests I remember walking in with
Robert Downey jr. the day of the tests
he was laughing and in great spirits and
completely at ease and he got in front
of the camera and started seeing the
lines I assure you the day weapons are
no longer needed to keep the peace I'll
happily transistor manufacturing bricks
and beams for baby hospitals making hemp
pants and the like but until that time
can I get your drink I don't we caught
on out about experience but it was one
of those rushes that I'm sure like
somebody would feel if they're about to
play a big sporting arena clean for the
ring or something like that
it was just like am I gonna pass out or
am I gonna nail this on that day that
Roberts screen tested it was clear that
there was no one else who can play that
part it was magic it was exactly the
feeling is a casting director with Kevin
with John with everyone that that we all
wanted to have that feeling like we have
it this is it this is our
[Music]
are you crying this is my destiny
Avengers Assemble
you
hi everyone happy comic-con week
continues because the Avengers endgame
blu-ray is getting ready to drop they're
dropping all kinds of deleted scenes and
bonus features
this is just part of that so we'll break
it all down and because this comic-con
will do a giveaway for the actual
blu-ray all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Avengers moment on the video in that
deleted scene on for me or when Black
Widow is talking to Hawkeye referencing
not judging people on their worst
mistakes
it's another callback to that red ledger
scene that they had in the original
Avengers movie so all the Hawkeye Black
Widow scenes during endgame reference
stuff from the other Avengers movies
like the line about Budapest when they
were on their way to four mirror but the
original speech her talking about the
red ledger was when she was trying to
make him feel better about what happened
with Loki and the tesseract and give him
this new call to action during the
original Avengers movie saying
everything she'd been doing since she
started working for Nick Fury and shield
before the events of Iron Man 2 and now
in The Avengers movies has been to atone
for the redness on her ledger the very
long list of people that she's killed as
the Black Widow after she graduated from
the Red Room so a lot of that they're
actually going to address during the
Black Widow movie kind of in present day
but also through flashbacks to when she
was a young girl in training there's
been a lot of confusion with the
timeline of that because Black Widow is
dead in present-day
our version of Black Widow in the Black
Widow movie is starring that version all
the present-day stuff for that movie
with the Jelena Bulova Black Widow is
supposed to take place after Captain
America Civil War but before the
beginning of Avengers endgame because
she still has the red hair but it's not
the red hair from avengers endgame where
she had just let her hair grow out over
that five year time span so there was a
little bit of blonde mixed into it this
is the classic red before she showed up
at the beginning of avengers endgame
with it really short and blonde I've
seen a lot of interesting Jelena Bulova
theories about why our Nat Black Widow
would have dyed her hair blonde at the
beginning of Avengers endgame I did a
whole preview video for the movie a
little while ago because we got a really
cool behind-the-scenes look at
taskmaster trying to go after them in a
giant tank then later her and Jelena
Bulova in get it
Budapest so it seems like they're going
to somehow pay off all these Budapest
Easter eggs that have been in The
Avengers movies there are a couple other
really big Black Widow deleted scenes
that we know about there was a whole
subplot that they cut out of the movie
of
trying to find homes for all the kids
who lost their parents to the snap in
that five-year time jump because Thanos
his first snap was meant to be random
you have families where both parents or
the only parent would get snapped and
there'd be all these little kids just
standing there in their ashes all alone
not knowing what the hell to do so Black
Widow was running the sort of backdoor
Avengers adoption agency they sort of
played the blip back more for comedy
during spider-man far from home there
was this huge housing crisis subplot at
the beginning of the film a lot of
people would get snapped leaving their
apartments their homes empty so other
people would move in new tenants aunt
Mae had this big joke about how she got
blip back in the grandmother of the
family living there I thought she was a
ghost
the wife thought she was a secret
mistress to her husband so more of a
comedic spin on that really big WTF
moments of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame but they kind of
designed the movie to be that they kind
of wanted to be the palette cleanser to
the downer ending from Avengers endgame
because so many people had died it was a
much longer scene on for me er where
Hawkeye died instead of Black Widow
pretty simple then there was another
version that was much much bigger with a
huge action scene of Thanos coming to
attack them in 2014 on Vermeer before
they could get the soul stone with this
huge pack of outriders Jeremy Renner's
said that the reason why they cut that
is because one it got too confusing
there was too much stuff going on at too
many big action set pieces and it
probably drove the budget way way higher
so they were probably looking for places
to cut and then really late in the game
they actually decided to change the
story and make Black Widow the person to
sacrifice herself so that Hawkeye could
survive and be with his family and
within the context of the story the
rewrites they did she didn't want
Hawkeye's family to be without their
father all the iron man's stuff that
they put on this is just part of the
Iron Man bonus features from the
Avengers end game blu-ray and because
Avengers endgame was Robert Downey jr.
'he's last Marvel film in like a really
big way for a good long while obviously
most of the blu-ray is dedicated to a
couple different characters him included
they have stuff going all the way back
to the original Iron Man film like you
see a younger version of Jon Favreau
talking about Robert Downey jr. during
this you see a young version of Kevin
Feige on the set behind the scenes of
the first Iron Man film there's a couple
of his original audition scenes when he
was auditioning for Iron Man if you've
never seen those scenes there's longer
versions of them
on the Iron Man blu-ray but they're like
20 minutes long so I can't post the
entire audition scenes in this video
okay done
done you're still buckingham palace what
do we go putting a break out the psyops
there it is there's a smile it's okay
yeah so it's natural les les muscles to
smile I gotta hand it to you guys every
single one he deserves a medal
when you watch his scenes in the more
recent films like Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame even Captain
America Civil War he definitely feels
like a very different character than he
does in these audition scenes so this is
really when he's starting to figure the
character out because if you watch that
original Iron Man film even though
obviously in the context of the universe
he evolves a lot and he changes a lot
the way Robert Downey jr. performs the
character now in present day feels a
little bit more natural like he's more
Robert Downey jr. walking around on set
then he is an actor trying to portray
Tony Stark Ironman definitely don't want
to dance with this guy we just wanted
gauntlet are you yawning in the middle
of this while I'm breaking it down huh
did you hear what I said stop listening
after you said you we need a plan okay
mr. clean is on his own page but if they
drop any more deleted scenes or any
other bonus features this week during
comic-con I'll try to do videos for them
there's so many other big trailers that
are gonna be dropping so there's some
big stuff that I don't get to right away
I'll try to cover it within the next
week but leave all your video requests
in the comments below
Friday and Saturday are really gonna be
the big days for panels and trailers so
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see the videos when I
post them alright that's I'm still
working on a spider-man far from home
deleted scenes video so I'll try to post
that tomorrow if there are too many
other big trailers but I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post that next
Marvel video while you wait for
everything click here for that Thor 4
teaser that's right we're getting a new
Thor film and click here for all my
spider-man far from home Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
see you guys tonight
[Music]